I'm just in order to survive with that
strategy you need to know these openings
inside out you need to know the
structures like the back of your hand
which you would assume he does but then
then but when Alejandro listed those
kind of factors the knight is saddled
out there on a 5d 4d 4 can be easy
defended by timely 5 and then the
penetration of the rook along the seat
you know along the line that's the C
line down to c7 well when you spin it
out for me like that then I might well
yes I can see why the world champion
magnus carlsen would be attracted to
this particular variation now having
said all of that rook d6 looks like a
perfectly plausible move to my eyes
first of all it does of course protect
the square c6 so it does allow the night
to jump back but far more importantly
black is preparing to put as much
pressure on okay yes there isn't there
is a technical there's a tactical
problem so when Brooke bc1 just say yes
so you're grabbing yes he filed at the
same time I'm grabbing the default yeah
and you cannot play the desired e5 in
this particular case because
unfortunately there's a pen and black
actually crashes through okay so how do
we handle so you think you might want to
go for example f4 and after for example
if now I can bring my knight into the
game cut oh no
because of a 5 there is a ok in this
particular case the rook is defending
the knight but it's conceivable that I
could start with the movie 5 and maybe
you would end up getting yourself a
little tied up here III would not advise
this so f4 and if you continued in the
same fashion then you might get what you
wanted right away with that rook and B
city you see one and maybe you just say
well maybe my look isn't doing anything
in particular on the d5 either alright
so again white is grabbing space his
bishops of beginning Dukes exert
themselves and this knight on a5 has not
played a role yet we'll keep a careful
eye on that and we're gonna shoot it
over to alejandro
for the game of wesley so because that
is also a critical headline game
Alejandro and did Wesley handle lavon's
opening well absolutely and if you're a
fan of the American this is good news
with the black pieces he seems to have
fully neutralized the armenian player
i'm very surprised at the decision of
LaVon to repeat something that he just
played where he himself neutralized his
opponent and it was Wesley that came up
with a new idea here after Castle the
game that I was mentioning between Anand
and Aronian Bishop takes every Bishop
takes have three c6 that was good enough
for equality tonight eventually jump to
c4 the bishop retreated to c7 and black
had no problems in the computer weak as
it is says this is fine for block
instead once they simply developed rook
a e8 he said I'm not gonna give you the
pair of bishops you're not even gonna
get that much and after 95 takes takes
Queen e6 all of this mainline engine
computer play so again Wesley mentioned
everybody looks at everybody's games
Wesley himself was there obviously he's
going to take a look at what Levon
Aronian is playing against vision on in
an opening that he himself placed so he
comes up with this idea
the engines are saying if you want an
advantage there's some kind of F 494 you
could try G for it doesn't really work
there's an f5 which leads to
weird simplifications that I don't
believe in the computer saying there's a
minor edge there I don't trust it and
after ok you won the game just kind of
one Westley's way you can see that black
has pretty much forced white entirely
into the back rank there's the pressure
on the c3 square you can imagine if I
get in f4 and again in rookie 5 I'll be
able to play for something but at the
moment White's pieces look a bit silly
this Queen is powerful on d5 this Bishop
which is usually dead has this pressure
over the c3 pawn I will never claim the
block is better in this position because
structurally he still has some issues
and white still can always simplify down
the e-file but a win for Levon that
seems a bit far-fetched know that I will
claim that after c7 c5 Wesley might be
the one saying that was Magnus doing
like come on BL you know Nichkhun for a
draw maybe cc5 will bring an advantage
to the American well very very good news
for Wesley so fans let's go to Maurice
Ashley in Zagreb who has a special guest
with him we are one of we're with one of
our dearest friends Leonard Oh Tess who
is a dgt specialist a photographer a
technical wizard what doesn't this man
do and he is with us at every single
event making sure that everything runs
smoothly
Leonard's it's funny interviewing you on
the show or been buddies for a long time
it's a pleasure to be on the show and to
watch the interviews from the other side
of the camera because usually I'm taking
photos of the people that you interview
thing like we're such a good friends
that like I kind of forget that you're
also part of the story sometime and
that's a bogus explanation yeah but
anyway
you take fantastic photos what is it
like being a part of high-level chess
and being able to document it for the
rest of history well what I really enjoy
about you GT offenses like I'm part of
history you know the events where
madness place is history
the last event where madness loss that
was in bill last year I was there and
that's history because like we don't
know when he will lose again you know
and it's it's so cool to actually like
witness all other great games from such
from so close by because they're not so
many players or not so many people who
get really can really watch over the
shoulders of the players during their
game right you're allowed to be there
just about all the time taking those
photos you can go right up next to the
players and we will take photos of them
and anybody ever get annoyed that you're
taking a photo too close I cannot really
recall that people are really annoyed of
course I have the feeling sometimes
hikaru he can look very angry but I
don't know if it's part of you know his
concentration or that he actually knows
that I'm there and wants me to go away
or something and I don't really feel
that from players they don't like me but
I get quite close and I take that
privilege which come with some courage
you see some of your great photos on
screen what is your favorite photo or
what photos do you remember you said I
cannot believe I got this shot I cannot
really recall a great moment but those
moments where there's a story are the
ones that are the best at least for me
if I know that like there's like an
amazing game for something by Magnus and
I can see like his hands are shaking
during the game and I can see its
opponent getting grumpier and and
anxious and Magnus at some point gets
more relaxed and and then it gets down
to like this final handshake it's
something that I really enjoy but
sometimes it's hard to judge those
photos without the context because I can
look them look at them later half a year
later and I forgot the story I'm like
hey what what did I actually take the
photo but like
once it's like in a tournament report
I'm like whoa yeah this actually
captured the moment and that's what I'm
looking for
you're also dgt specialist as we
mentioned has ever been a time when
something horrible happened in the dgt
boards and you're thinking oh my god I
got to fix this or I said the world
would not be able to watch what's going
on well it doesn't happen often
fortunately but first of like this event
like round two there was something wrong
with like the setup of the boards the
names were wrong with the with the
positions so that's something that I
have to fix fortunately I can do it of
course absolutely we also know that
tomorrow is your birthday happy birthday
thank you thank you getting up in age
now all of thirty-one
you've been enjoying zacchara any plans
for tomorrow no I've no plans depends
also on Wesley what his plans are right
this is plans are my plans Oh Magnus as
well if you guys of course and then we
all get to party yeah yeah see how
things progress today but uh no like for
example like right now with the Boomers
World Cup going on and like if the Dutch
team wins it's already like a great
birthday present for me good luck
hopefully that does happen we know it is
tied at half time thank you so much for
joining us and keep on doing the great
work thank you let it first of all one
of many people behind the scenes who
facilitate what we do
Thank You Maurice first of all it's zero
zero at half time wait a minute the
Dutch haven't won yet
it's Magga first holland second so we're
looking forward to a great match there
no question about it looking at the game
between Yann and on each I just think
it's a terrible position for an F oh I
have no idea what his preparation has
been because it seems like he's gone
into a position virtually by force where
he's simply much much worse and I would
go so far as to say losing again this
this whole game with Magnus Carlsen and
this ending is a little bit confounding
and confusing but the more you look at
it you do
why I mean the Magnus's is just played
the move rook on b1 2 c1 by the way so
he is inviting this we thought that he
could play rook da somebody wrote to the
aliens why is that
ePHI Bishop takes e5 is not possible but
before we get into this we got a phone
call from New York hello and welcome to
the show
hi guys you just saw some Queens oh
honey I just want to interested about
mindset in psychology check the other
thing when I heard the wisly talking
about his game coming up with Magnus
using I'm happy just to finish second in
the 20 minutes I mean I don't want to
turn me off I would never see any you
guys are not a great quiet thing oh I
didn't want to be second you guys want
to win the tournament and you think that
it shows maybe he'll never be a World
Series of Canada because that kind of
attitude also as far as the commentators
of Angelo who remember show behind in
1970 so he did the vicious boxing match
with a pellet I pretend 1972 famously
doing the PBS shows of the Fischer
Spassky match and that got really of wow
I want to say USA audience tens of
millions of people were watching Shelby
show let's not forget that this is the
grand chest [ __ ] right and that
everybody wants to be in the top four to
go to the finals
yes securing second I know it sounds
like a whirlwind patience but also yeah
those points the money and you get to
London hey you know you're just trying
to qualify I mean if you look at it
there's the current standings that
Magnus Carlsen is 13 Hikari and my
congressional graph have 9 points so you
see Wesley so was 7
yeah imagine four above the he takes
clear second has got 15 suddenly is that
22 points in his pocket right and he's
looking at London and saying you know am
I ready to book my ticket
I'm Sinquefield also looking at the
prize fund as well we see first prize
90,000 then we drop down to 60,000
place and then we drop down even more
20,000 by to 40,000 circles and this is
a huge huge there you can see it
huge difference in prizes and
Grantchester points as well and I was
only thinking about this whole situation
last night you know I was thinking about
Wesley and how you know okay it's not
it's not a showman that I mean their
disappointment because you kind of want
this flamboyant saying yes he's gonna
push hard yeah every game is gonna go in
for the kill but if we like look at it
realistically you know by him taking a
draw I mean the game that was he was
always gonna have to dedicate like all
his energy to was this game it'll get
much a begin against aronia because a
ronin of course wants to pull him he was
to pull him and so is it that is it that
well well let's let's get our we hunt
Rhoda jump in on this conversation as
well as we see how Wesley got into
second place pragmatic good decision bad
decision let's say I will agree 100
percent of what you guys are saying the
tournament situation says Wesley just go
for the drop and there is nothing that
you can really criticize about it
because of this event but the color has
another question the color also has a
question does this impact you know your
thoughts on Wesley being a real world
championship candidate and that's a
different question altogether and I
think the answer is yeah it impacts very
negatively because I think that at that
level you can have this much respect for
Magnus you can't say I'm gonna be world
champion but I'm gonna play him in this
tournament with white I'm not even gonna
try I think that Wesley is a very
pragmatic player but he doesn't have
that fire that I see some of the other
players trying to get into the World
Championship for example when favi
wanted his world candidates tournament
and that last round against Chris chair
he needed a draw that's all he needed
all the other games had finished right
and he didn't offer the draw he ground
down Chris check he's that type of
player and we've seen over and over
again that these
super super grandmasters they have that
fire Magnus how many times has he won a
tournament and then get a player no
matter what color and he tries to beat
them and I I agree again the way the it
was set up for Wesley yesterday
everything says play for them play for
me no no sorry play for the draw yeah
you know this is the tournament
situation we have right now this is
what's going on this is the prize money
this is how do you get to the finals the
finals were what matters I completely
understood but Wesley overall as a
player has never struck me as somebody
that has that fire must win situations
where he just comes up and says or
actually not in must-win situation he
needs that he sometimes pulls through
but when there's situations where he
doesn't need to win but a draw is okay
he's never the type of player that will
go super risk and say I'm just better
than you I'm gonna meet you
he's the player that says so I'm plus
one plus two make some draws I'll get to
maybe first place maybe second and it's
fine nothing wrong with the approach
he'll be in the top ten for a very long
time he's incredibly talented but a
world championship top challenger I mean
that's a completely different level you
have to go to a different level we used
to call that the killer instinct that
you really really needed to develop a
killer instinct we saw it in Magnus
before he became world champion in 2013
here in the sink tell Cup in st. Louis
last round all he needs is a draw he
refuses to draw against Levon Aronian
goes on to win the moment that Alejandro
was just mentioning in Berlin all he
needs is a draw Fabiano is the
challenger to the world champion many
players would have just left into the
arms that draw no let me grind it out
and win it so this is a killer instinct
now where Wesley
and I don't want to be too critical it
was actually last year I they were it
was London and they had to have a
playoff yes between Leslie and Bobby and
Wesley seemed to just accept that he
wasn't gonna good see this this I can I
can get down with I can actually I I
don't see anything fundamentally wrong
with Wesley's approach it's been well
known that a certain you know when you
pay these long tournaments I mean he's a
Fisher said I have my eye on who I'm
gonna beat and who I'm not gonna beat
and Wesley is doing the same your
situation where he refused to try that I
kind of agree with but I mean they're
kind of I I think the problem with
Wesley the purchase is not gonna get him
supporters people are not gonna fall in
love and go hey well it's a yeah let's
get behind Wesley but whether he can
become well champion I don't know I I
think that's kind of different question
altogether I don't think he's missing
the killer instinct I think is very
practical I think you know in some sense
if you're in it for the long haul you're
just trying to gain experience your
biding your time and if you have that
confidence that you're gonna do it then
okay it's good to climatized it's good
to put yourself under pressure what do i
but trying you definitely have to try so
I would be critical of that that London
attempt not even trying to get into
London as opposed to whether we should
Harold Fabiana for trying I mean it
depends on the situation because I'm not
not entirely familiar with the game but
I can show you if it was a complex game
where three results were in the air
I'm sure Fabiana would have snatched
that then like Magnus Carlsen here for
instance I'm sure if Maxime could offer
a draw Magnus would probably say no look
at my position it's amazing it's like no
risk whatsoever for me to play on right
alejandro jump in here and tell us we've
just seen I believe the move Bishop g5
by Magnus yeah Magnus didn't choose the
number one line of the engine but still
a very good one and I am still not sure
why the engine things that was the
number one line I just wanted to point
out really quickly what the engine
wanted to play and rugby c1 seems like
the most
natural correct move in the world they
just wanted to play King g2 and they
were claiming this is some kind of
zugzwang
because if you do play the move rook a
d8 I have d5 and this is where this gets
pretty weird taking on d5 as possible
and now there's ideas of playing Bishop
g5 and attacking this rook you don't
want to play f6 we'll see soon yf6
matters and if you move the rook away
I'll take with the pawn and I have this
passer on the six and it's just really
strong computers are saying the night
cutting doesn't get back eventually a
you can remove the room that rook will
penetrate to the seventh rank it's all
awful but there's also this resource of
Bishop f6 now tactically this doesn't
work because of e5 and if you take this
pawn I'll take your exchange and because
the night is so off place blacks losing
same thing if you take my bishop I'll
take your rook down the exchange for
black two points to compensate but again
it's the activity that pieces is just
not enough especially with rook b5
coming and I'm taking the point exact
now the difference is when you play
rugby c1 and you play rook b8 d 5 takes
Bishop g5 after Bishop f6 v 5 Bishop
takes g5 it's that rook so if there's
ever a computer like explanation or
white rook BC one it's not the best move
in the world this is it I don't know
anybody that things like this but I have
an engine so I should explain why the
engines were thinking King g2 is better
what Magnus has played looks very
logical rugby c1 rook da Bishop g5 and
this is a typical groom filled trick
where you force black to react against
Bishop g5 because you don't want to move
the rook again and allow d5 and you
don't want to play f6 because it shuts
out your bishop but guess what you don't
have a choice so f6 played Bishop e3 and
I'm fully expecting Maxime to retreat
the night he hasn't played yet but I've
I think this is the time if you don't
move the knight back you might not get
another chance right right and the
problem is that tactically this isn't so
great for black after I play d5 and I
take the computers are likely to take
with the rook in this case this
threatens rook takes c6 tactically if
the rook moves away I trade and played
rook c7 that's also horrible so you
really do have to take on d5 take on d5
clearly you cannot take on d5 here
because the Knights hanging
and Bishop c4 is a trick so you can
solve both by playing 97 but now there's
a couple of ways to getting a very clear
advantage for white maybe decisive one
is to simply push the rook down to c7
the other thing you don't have a threat
play Bishop f4 Knight takes d5 and you
are so pinned after root D 1 and Bishop
c4 that you're gonna eventually run out
of moves and this night will just fall
it seems like you would be on time of
doing things you just aren't computers
giving a decisive advantage in this
position so still a very tough road
ahead for Maxine why share that graph -
is playing very very well perhaps not
the number one King G to move but this
number to rugby c1 good enough for a
huge edge point II was giving me that
position and said what are your
candidate moves Rick c1 just put the
Brooklyn c1 I'll take that you'll take
that line and you've been well-trained
what's belong on Oprah files Jovi I get
it I mean I love it
just a quick glance not too much has
happened in the game of Levon Aronian we
were making a joke on our set Fischer
random chest by Levon Aronian as he's
just put all of his pieces on the first
rank and just kind of move move them
around the Queen c2 was played and
rookie six so again not too much is
going on here other than the fact that
Wesley so is very happy with the outcome
of this particular opening unleash Gary
well he's just winning Sweeney just like
oh I mean it's it's just terrible a game
that we haven't really looked at too
much we'll just look at it now is the
game between Hikaru Nakamura our
Grantchester or defending champion who's
up against this one ofone Anand who's
been a great customer Karmakar oh very
very surprising but Hikaru does have a
very big score against this XI I
actually do think that White's a little
bit
here I've always liked the central
majority versus the so-called Greenfeld
Queen side pawns so I think he carros a
bit better but this year will be more or
less satisfying the opening I was just a
bit kind of curious about this pawn the
c5 break that plays into warts hands so
after Queen takes d5 he carves castle
Cara wants to play rook b1 rook c1 for a
lot of Cara's moves are easy
I thought Knight b6 might have actually
come before the moves live but z5 was
played I don't think that's a problem
and we're here am expecting Knight b6
which is a tempo there you can see what
yes I was referring to you know even to
to victories in him and he carries favor
when you think about these greatest of
grades and some really lopsided score
like the 4-0 lopsided score that neppo
had over Magnus joerger like what yeah
does that come from and the lopsided
score that Magnus has over Hikaru that
was also I like the ones that were even
steven you know for for 28 draws is a
bit depressing I mean I like it when
it's just unknown you know like the hick
Anish against you know poverty to be
it's like anything can go close right
now one of the people in the chasing
pack the honor is the Fabiano dingle
aaron can't get into a tie for second
cuz he's only at 50% this is that moment
and Dean is actually sacrificed a pawn